all right this is from the
new york post it says south carolina has
given the green light for condemned
prisoners in the state to be executed by
firing squad final approval came friday
after the state department of
corrections said renovations had been
completed
on a new death chamber where the
executions can take place in the state
capital of colombia
the electric chairs are the state's
primary method of execution but a may
2021 law now allows prisoners prisoners
to choose to die by lethal injection or
firing squad the state said in a press
release i'm just mentioning this because
this is you talk about common sense
i mean it's it's
it's crazy
that we've done away with the firing
squad
in so many of the states that still
allow um executions it's crazy we've
done away with executions in general in
many states but even the ones that allow
it getting rid of the firing side like
what's what's the reason for that
well the reason is pretty simple it's
just it's just kind of like
trying to hide it's trying to sanitize
what what's happening
it's it's not about um
more humane methods of execution the
electric chair lethal injection
these certainly are not
painless ways to die
especially the electric chair
but
it sanitizes it a little bit and allows
you to hide a little bit from what's
happening which is that we're killing
someone
just justly rightfully
someone who this is the punishment that
they have warranted that they deserve
because of their actions
you know people who through their
monstrous actions have given society
really no choice but to deal with them
in this way
yet there's always this even it just
shows you something about our society
that even when it comes to how we
execute people i mean you're killing
them
and we still don't want to confront that
we're so afraid of death
and of confronting the reality of death
and confronting our own mortality that
even in executions we try to we try to
hide it
by putting someone on a
you know
strapping them down on a gurney and
injecting them with something and
we think that will somehow i don't know
what it what it's supposed to achieve
exactly
seems to me that firing squad is
obviously the cheapest way to go about
it the quickest way most the simplest
way
um it also much much less opportunity
for things to go wrong when you hear
about cases of electric chair or lethal
injection
or that's administered to someone that's
the other thing we talk about
administering it right it's death we're
not killing someone we're just
administering it
uh but you hear of it being administered
and it goes wrong and then there's it
takes multiple attempts and obviously
it's agonizingly painful for the person
for the for the condemned
so not a lot of opportunity for it to go
wrong quick cheap and uh and also i
would think the most painless of all the
options
not a fun thing to experience but the
most painless
this is what this is what every state
should be and also you know rather than
dragging it out you know we we establish
that somebody is guilty of a horrific
crime and then 27 years later we bring
them in to
do the deed
how about we establish that they're
guilty they're convicted and i don't
know the next day you bring them out in
front of the firing squad
and that's it
[Music]